Rob welcome back to computer found these
strange times that we find ourselves
recording in you've got the green screen
up there we're having a few laggy
problems with the communications what
are you going to talk about today then
yeah I thought today it would make sense
to talk about GPT three because before
we had those videos about language
models and transformers and GPT two
people seem to like I think those came
out quite well and now there's a new one
so is it so ok what's that what's the
deal eleven it is both bigger and better
that's that's the headline
so like the thing about the thing about
GPT two is just that it was much bigger
than anything that came before right it
was more parameters and just a larger
language model and that was kind of the
point of that paper right the point it
was trying to make is like people in
natural language processing has spent a
tremendously long time working on all of
these clever things that you can do it
getting in the nitty-gritty of the
technical technical stuff for like
detailed fine-tuning for these different
benchmarks that they have and so on and
GPG too was opening I just saying well
what if we just made a really really
huge one what would happen and it turns
out that even without any fine-tuning by
which I mean well I we talked about all
of this before so I won't get into that
detail but like that it that GPT to
could do reasonably well on all of these
different tasks even though it hadn't
been trained on those tasks it was
trained purely as a language model which
means all it's trying to do is predict
the next word or the next token given
what its seen so far and so that was
kind of an interesting finding that if
you just took this like quite simple
architecture the transformer is not that
complicated and architecture and the
data set is not like a fancy or
sophistic it's not like a highly what am
i saying it's not like a high effort
structured data set is just like a giant
pile of text you're trying to make sure
it's good quality text but
it's it's just unstructured just any
text you could get from the internet and
it's able to perform reasonably well
sometimes state-of-the-art sometimes not
on the all of these like specific
benchmarks for different natural
language processing tasks and that was
very impressive and the thing I think I
said this at the time is that the graphs
were still curving upwards you have
these like we're not curving upwards but
they were straight
they weren't cutting down so generally
speaking you start to get diminishing
returns right you can't just keep making
the model bigger forever yeah that's the
thing is like you usually would expect
it to plateau but at the level of GPD to
it was not so not only was this model
bigger than anything that came before
but also there was an indication that
like with that just scaling up is like
we haven't reached the limits of that
yet and that was kind of surprising
because yeah because you would generally
expect these things to plateau right you
would expect to hit the limits of the
data like the information contained in
the data the data set size but also
maybe the the training regime maybe the
the whole approach right what's the
biggest airplane you can build it's
pretty big but they're like comes a
point where the aeroplane approach
doesn't work anymore and if you want to
go higher you need a rocket right you
need like a whole different approach you
can't just scale up what you have what
they found with g52 was not only could
you make the model much bigger and it
continued to get better but also the
rate at which you continue to get better
is still pretty much a straight line
with the scaling of smaller models so
since that time various people have got
on the bigger language models trained
and tried making new things you know
bigger and bigger language models and
they keep doing better and better kind
of according to what you would expect
and then for GPT 3 what open hi has done
has come along and said essentially the
same thing they said for GPT 2 which is
ok
but what if we made a bigger one and
everybody's like what we did we did make
a bigger one it's like no what if we
made like a bigger no somebody's plotted
this graph and then there's somebody
there at the back of the room going
that's still going up there yeah right
like how far can we ride this thing
let's find out so so you remember the
the GPT two they released the hundred
and seventeen million parameter model
and they didn't release the larger
models immediately right because there
was some concerns about possible misuse
and over time they steadily released
larger and larger models the largest DBT
to model was 1.5 billion parameters so
GPT three is a hundred and seventy five
billion parameters well okay yeah you
need a lot of a lot of compute and a lot
of money to run it so so yeah they did
have to do some clever engineering
because like gbt - you can put it on a
single machine at inference time whereas
i don't think you can do that with GPT
three I think you need a sort of a
cluster to run it but yeah so the big
finding with this giant model which
which is about ten times bigger it's a
hundred and seventeen times bigger than
GPT - and about ten times bigger than
the previous biggest thing which was
chewing n LG watch it and what they find
is when they look at the graphs they're
still going up right we can we could we
could still go bigger and it does look
like it would continue to get better so
how good is it some of the main
takeaways are when you have it write an
article and you ask human beings to
differentiate articles written by gbg3
from articles written by humans they get
it right
about 52% of the time I'm looking at the
table here it says human accuracy in
identifying whether short news articles
are model generated these are articles
of about 200 words and basically they
tried generating with all of the
different sizes so GPT 3 small medium
and large on this are I think equivalent
sizes to the GPT 2 ones and then you can
see how the accuracy with which humans
are able to identify just steadily goes
down basically the small model they are
76 percent of the time able to tell if
correctly if it's human or AI and then
just steadily drops down until you get
to the one hundred and seventy five
billion parameter model whether at 52
percent what I thought was it would be
fun to run a little experiment with
everybody at home because they had the
thing generate some poems and there are
samples in the paper the way that you
get this model to produce things is you
give it some text and then you say and
now it's your turn to continue from here
so they gave it something which kind of
looks like it's from a compendium of
poetry so it has you know the title of
the poem by this person and then the
full text of the poem and then the title
of another poem so what I thought it
would do because we know this the poem
we know the poet that GPG 3 is trying to
imitate that I could try reading like
randomly picking one of wallace stevens
as actual poems and randomly picking one
of these I think these aren't cherry
picked either
yeah I'm curated completions yeah so and
then we'll see so I'm going to randomly
pick one of each and then I'm gonna
randomly decide which one I'll read
first so you don't get any clues okay so
this pound are both by Wallace Stevens
this first poem is called
shadows on the way I must have shadows
on the way if I am to walk I must have
each step taken slowly and alone to have
it ready-made and I must think in lines
of gray to have dim thoughts to be my
guide must look on blue and green and
never let my eye forget the color is my
friend and purple must surround me too
the yellow of the Sun is no more
intrusive than the bluish snow that
falls on all of us I must have gray
thoughts and blue thoughts walk with me
if I am to go away at all
that's one pun the other one is titled
fab leo of Florida bark of phosphor on
the balmy beach move outward into heaven
into the alabaster's and night blues
foam and cloud are one sultry moon
monsters are dissolving fill your black
hull with white moonlight there will
never be an end to this droning of the
surf everybody place your bets the
problem is people who know poetry really
well it would be well placed to decide
you know which of these they prefer or
whatever the chances are they'll they'll
know the originals so it's hard to get a
fair test without magical on Google I
have no idea which is which I mean I
don't know should we reveal it here one
can be used Philo she let people have a
think about it or should we say at the
end yeah maybe at the end of the video
oh she's one thing and at the risk of
offending some poetry fans it can be
thought of as kind of ethereal and maybe
not so grounded in fact and therefore
it's okay to predict that sort of stuff
and to emulate a poet but what about
things like scientific papers if you
fail it enough science enough scientific
papers do you think could it come up
with something that we've not really
realized before or or something new yeah
so my instinct is to say no it's just
predicting the next word right it's just
a language model it doesn't have the
ability to build the kind of abstract
mental structures that you need in order
to actually kind of synthesize new
knowledge but there's a kind of an
outside view that says that we thought
that about a bunch of things that it's
now seems to be doing so I'm not going
to say that it definitely couldn't do
that
so so one example of a task which it got
better at tremendously better at is
arithmetic which is kind of an
interesting task because again it's a
language model it's not trying to do
arithmetic it's not designed to do
arithmetic but so with GPT 2 if you put
in 2 plus 2 equals and get it to give
you the next token it will give you a 4
but that's not very surprising like
that's not very impressive because you
would expect in its data set to see that
string 2 plus 2 followed by the string
for very many times that's pure
memorization right the thing doesn't
have to have any understanding of what
letters or what numbers are at all it
can just see the secrets of tokens give
you the next one and then the problem
gets harder and harder the more like 23
plus 48 or something that's more
difficult because it's less likely that
that specific string has appeared in the
in the training data set right so this
gets more and more difficult and more
and more like actual reasoning you
couldn't see me doing big hair quotes
there the longer the numbers get right
if you can reliably add 10 digit numbers
together then it's hard to deny that
what you're really doing hasn't you have
to really be doing addition right you
know there's no way you could memorize
to that yeah but it's kind of
interesting because GPT 3 does way
better but it can't add ten digit
numbers so let me find her let me find
the graph because they graphed this so
it starts to run out stealing
effectively right was a humanist yep
so what I'm looking at now is a graph of
performance on a bunch of different
arithmetic tasks and you can see that
just going up to like two digit addition
GPT to does pretty poorly
so the 1.3 billion parameter model which
I guess is the closest equivalent better
than chance but not much
at all so the thing is so to do to
addition and three-digit addition are
things which like by the time you're at
three digit addition you're not going to
be memorizing from the data set because
firstly I think that the cleaning of the
data set made some attempt to remove if
there was something that was just like a
giant table of the times tables or
something like that I think they tried
to remove that from the data set and
secondly if you're if you're doing
three-digit addition that's a million
different possible problems right
it's like quite a lot of network
capacity to do by memorization people
learn multiplication tables and this is
like apparently the most effective way
of teaching something that works like a
human brain and then you have some
procedural rules for taking you like you
memorize the three plus three is six and
then you have these procedural rules
about like carrying and and those kinds
of things to do larger additions and
then you iteratively like systematically
apply that but yeah the larger the
numbers get the harder it is to memorize
and they actually ran an analysis so
they searched for the addition problems
they searched for 2,000 of them just
looking through the whole data set does
38 plus 49 exist anywhere in this data
set and they found 17 matches writes
0.85 percent of the of these problems
occurred in the database but GPG threes
performance on two-digit addition is
extremely good it's basically 100% of
the time to do to subtraction only
slightly worse and then three digit
addition and subtraction again it's
getting like 80 percent 90 percent and
it's a big jump from the smaller models
what they're kind of suggesting in the
paper is that it has actually learned
how to learn
like that's what that's that that's the
the interpretation of this that they're
pushing that the the in order for in
order to perform sufficiently well at
this language modeling task the best
thing to do is to actually while looking
at the context learn specific rules for
how the context behaves so that you can
continue it more accurately okay yeah
and so I have an example I have like a
way of thinking about this which is not
that tight in analogy but I think it
might be helpful yeah which is okay so
suppose you've got your doing like sim
toril you have a robotics task you're
training an agent to do some thing with
a robot right running things on the
physical robot is super slow so you're
using a simulation but you have a
problem which is that the simulation is
not exactly the same as reality you have
this physics model that you've built
that is supposed to simulate exactly you
have the robot and the environment at
the robot so that it can learn in the
simulation and transfer it in practice
that doesn't work very well because it's
really hard to know you always have some
uncertainty about just little variables
you know how much like each part of the
robot weighs or whatever because you
built it but like what's the what's the
coefficient of friction on the ground at
the spot where the robot is right now
like you have to estimate right and it
might not be right and so if you train
something if you take your best guess
put it in and you train a system it
might find a policy which is a policy of
like doing some kind of leap that that's
the best way to achieve whatever it is
you've told it to do like get from here
to there quickly or something and then
you have a problem because then if they
if the it's relying on the current
efficient coefficient of friction being
this specific thing and then you run it
on the real robot and the thing
completely falls over because the it's
out of the distribution it was trained
on so one thing that people do is when
they're simulating it they randomly vary
it right you say we think that the
coefficient of friction here is around
this number but we're actually going to
give it every time every like episode
we're going to give it a random value
somewhere in the range from like 0.9 of
that
by one of that you know and then the the
machine learning system is going to
learn a policy that's able to handle any
correlation of friction within that
range she was learning to adapt right
right well that's the thing so there's
two different things that could happen
here one is the model could learn oh if
I do this kind of leaping thing then
some of the time I completely stack it
and it's very embarrassing
so I'm going to just do like a shuffling
thing right that's like much more
reliable that works across a wide range
of friction values right that's one
thing you could do but there you've kind
of sacrificed some performance right
yeah but if your model is more is more
sophisticated it could learn something
like okay first just slide your foot
along the ground a bit to get a feel for
what the friction is like yeah and then
if it's correct do the leap otherwise do
something else or like adjust how you're
leaping so that it always works exactly
and nothing necessarily changed for that
except the power of the model right if
your model is too small then it's not
going to be able to learn something as
complicated as measure the friction and
then do one of these five possible
things depending on the friction right
it's only going to be able to learn one
thing that it could do and so it has to
just learn one that does okay on all
friction hose but if you have a larger
model you can learn a better policy
which actually adapts I don't know I
like this is this is purely I'm not like
talking about a specific paper or
anything this is just a thing that I
thought of and so what they're
suggesting I think in this paper is that
gbg3 is doing something similar that in
order to perform really well at this
language modeling task it's actually
learning online from the context what
the task is that needs to be done
gradually I mean I think it's like it's
a step on the path
it's not like us it's not dramatically
closer than we would expect or anything
like that what they're interested in
mostly in this paper is gbg3 as a few
short learner which is so you have the
standard machine learning model is you
give the thing loads and loads of data
right the more data points the better
but sometimes you have a few short
learning problem which is where you have
to learn using only a few examples so
let's say for example your phone you
want to unlock your phone
right you can train a model that does
all kinds of face recognition and stuff
but in this case you want to train a
classifier to distinguish this face from
other faces but it's only gonna get you
know you're going to give it like three
pictures of yourself whereas usually for
a classify you would want to be giving
them thousands so that's like a few
short learning problem and and so you
can kind of you can kind of imagine this
is all kind of fuzzy because it's like
you can think of it as when you're
giving the thing the context you can
give it examples and how many examples
you give it is a bit like just giving
training samples to a machine learning
system but what's impressive is that
gbg3 seems to be able to do these tasks
with what would be very very few
examples compared to standard machine
learning methods right the thing that's
kind of interesting is when you look at
we can stick with arithmetic stick with
addition the number of examples that you
give it makes a big difference if you
just say what's you know this number
plus this number equals it will get that
right a certain percentage of the time
but if you say you know 10 plus 10
equals 20 you know 25 plus 30 equals 55
you know and give it a few of those then
the performance gets much better there's
various different ways that you could
interpret this easy it actually learning
how to do addition from looking at your
examples
or is it just figuring out that what you
want is addition is it is it is it
learning addition or is it like locating
addition in the space of possible tasks
that it already knows how to do kind of
unclear for all pretty much every task
they try it in the zero shot the one
shot and the few shot settings and they
they look at how well it performs and it
consistently does you know better the
more examples you give it up to the size
of the context obviously you can't I
think you can only give it 2048 tokens
which actually is a very large and I
like that's much bigger than most other
language models out there but that they
find it does better it does better than
where you give it but also the ratio
seems to go up the larger the language
model is right so so all of the models
do better with more examples yes but the
difference between the zero shot and a
few shot is bigger for the bigger models
so it suggests that perhaps the larger
models are actually like making better
use of that information in the context
to actually learn things yes right right
it's less about just like using the
context to find the relevant parts of
the training data to sort of parrot back
that you've memorized and more about
actually learning what to do from the
context like recognizing that what's
happening is addition and then actually
doing addition yeah because you have to
have some way to account for the fact
that this thing is reliably doing
addition when only a very small number
of those addition problems actually
occurred in the training dataset yes
the other thing that's interesting about
it is apparently when it gets them wrong
it tends to get them wrong in sort of
human plausible ways okay yeah exactly
exactly and that is another indication
that what it's
here is is something like actual actual
addition but that's pretty exciting and
there's a sense in which you know it you
could imagine it learning the rules of
addition sort of in the same way and
that it learns the rules of grammar in
order to change something into a
question then you swap these two words
around and add a question mark or
whatever it is you know in order to do
addition then you pull out the thing
that you've memorized for these two and
add it and then do it again to this one
or whatever and that is the kind of
thing that you that I most people I
didn't expect a transformer trained in
this very straightforward way to be able
to learn and the big takeaway is we've
gone we've gone 117 times bigger than
GPT 2 and GPT two they started doing it
because the curves are leveling off
they're still not leveling off so yeah
we don't know how far we can push this
type of language modeling by a little
bit further yet at least in this case
the first one was gbg3 and the second
one was so the bluish snow and etc etc
that was the only thing I was thinking
about never so thinking one no it's kind
of bluish white great well and it also
you know it's cell phone under a blue
sky it's on